i go to america
the aim of the movie was to show the
dangers of
trumpets we wanted a show
it was the end of democracy in america
what is more dangerous
this virus or the democratic
democrats democrats this is unlike any
other kind of filmmaking
i'm stephen miller sorry i'm like we had
to do whatever we could to get this
movie out before the election
at the time it felt complete madness
[Music]
[Applause]
we made the borat sea call to show that
hate lies and conspiracies enable this
slide into authoritarianism
and we wanted to get it out before the
election to remind people of the danger
of trumpism
high five we thought paul rat was the
ideal person to illuminate what trump
has
really believed because borap was a bit
more misogynistic
he was a bit more into white supremacy
he was a bit more into caging children
and by being further than the
interviewee he would allow
them to really reveal themselves hillary
clinton drink
the uh blood of children that's what
we've heard yeah
i've heard it's it's been said when
sasha
told me that he was planning on doing
this movie i thought
i don't know how you stay relevant you
know there's everybody doing this in
late night
and doing great jokes but ultimately
when he said that he was bringing
borah's daughter into the story line i
thought it was great
because honestly when this country is
still litigating women's rights
i thought well you know what it's time
for borat to come back
and have his daughter help with this
cause
it's about a girl from a patriarchal
society where
women are property where they're owned
by their fathers
and are brought up to be then owned by
their husbands and it's a
girl who rejects that entire philosophy
ella no
no no hannah and it's also the story of
the world's most misogynistic man
becoming a feminist i want you to make a
hotzy
out of this nazi we can do it i mean the
challenges of this
are obviously you've got this emotional
father daughter story
you've got a comedy movie where you're
trying to make sure the set pieces are
as good as everything you've seen before
you've got the satire you've also got
this
continually evolving writer's room in
that we're reacting
to stuff that real people are doing
and all of that culminates in a scene at
the rally at the end where
borat's looking for tuta his daughter
and i go on stage
playing a character called country steve
this scene was kind of the culmination
on every level
of what's unique about this film and
what's challenging about
about this specific film we gotta get up
and fight for this beautiful country the
united states of america
i don't see very many masks out there
that makes you
that makes you instant criminals this is
a very important scene for the
story this is when tutar makes this
emotional turn
this decision to save her father's life
essentially
she's living her life as the first ever
kazakh woman
to follow her own trajectory and not be
owned by another man
and she decides to give it all up this
story point was always written
but how to execute it had to change
as soon as kovid set in los angeles
locked down and there was the discussion
of
when do we start up again daily i was
calling up monica going there must be a
way there must be a way
and the moment i saw these anti-lockdown
protesters
i thought these are the perfect people
for borat to be with we should shoot
this scene with horat's daughter
live in the middle of one of these
anti-lockdown rallies
and the rally became part of that story
which was a brilliant
addition by the writers and the team
and if the purpose of the movie is to be
a 90-minute reminder
of the failings of trumpism then perhaps
the biggest
failing of all was the willful
incompetence when it came to coronavirus
and so we came up with this idea of i go
on stage and i sing this song about
all trump's opponents should be injected
with the wuhan fleet
obama what we're gonna do inject him
with the wooham flute
inject him with the
[Music]
what happened was they told me about the
idea of uh singing in this rally
with guys with machine guns and i set to
work
writing the song and the key thing was
to
write not a comedy song but a song that
was real before that
event that would have been like the real
band would have played
and was authentic so it had that country
blue grass sound
obama was a traitor america
he hated aaron is kind of brilliant at
getting these songs that are it
perfectly in the genre that aren't
parodies and
what we wanted to do was to get the
two conspiracy theorists called jim and
jiren have them
come up with some lyrics for it we'd
already written it but
some of the lines that they come up with
we then incorporated
into the song so the first line was
obama was a traitor america he hated
that was their line so they actually are
credited
as helping write the lyrics obviously
with the rest of the great writing team
dr fouchy what we're gonna do
it had to be a call and response song
but we needed the audience to
immediately
feel at ease but also would sing back
the chorus
so they had to be catchy immediately so
that was really my aim
with getting the melody right and
getting that theme right
and you know those are the actual
responses
w.h.o what are we gonna do
[Music]
yeah we had camera operators hidden all
throughout the audience that
everyone was on walkie but you're
dealing with such a
suspicious crowd everyone there is on
high alert
and a lot of people have semi-automatic
weapons and are looking around for
infiltrators basically so for me this
little guy running around talking into a
walkie-talkie
is very suspicious jason's needing to
direct probably
15 camera operators between people with
iphones and small
cameras and bag cams and i would just
kind of go up to operators
and just whisper okay make sure you've
got good eyes on her make sure that
guy's gonna be a good reaction make sure
you're getting that guy
let's here forgas them up like the
germans
there's so many layers to the scene
sasha's trying to do this
performance but he also has to be
believable to these
two men that he's been with for the last
five days
and that they're gonna still approach
his daughter and
try to work on behalf of him i was
exhausted by this point because i this
was the fifth day of staying in
character
you know waking up in the morning having
breakfast with these guys
lunch dinner getting drunk with them
going to sleep sometimes they'd come to
my room in the middle of the night
and i was really terrified i thought i
can't do it they're going to see through
the character
how am i going to get all the story
points across how we're going to make
sure that it's still funny
it was definitely a real challenge
over there she's over there she's over
there
to the right
you know we have this song that we knew
sasha wanted to sing and at the same
time we have this emotional scene
with tutar and jim and jerry and she's
gotta do that in a way that doesn't feel
like
a scene that feels like an actual
interaction to those guys the thing
about
maria bakalova who's this incredible
actress
she has to go through the emotional
change where she
hears that her dad's gonna die if she
lives her life and she has to go through
that
change on screen in one take in a real
rally with people around you with
machine guns
normally if you had a lead actor who was
going through such a pivotal
scene the director would give them five
ten fifteen takes
she's gonna do it in one go he needs to
go back to be with
a man from washington dc and if you do
not do that they will kill him
and you're trying to capture the moments
but you also have to stay in the genre
of the movie so
you have to have the push in on her face
when she realizes her dad's going to die
you know you've got one
chance to get this right that's why the
camera work is brilliant directions
brilliant
i will not talk with him but tell him
that i will do it
most of the movie are these scenes with
real people then once we're in there
whatever happens happens we basically
are just creating an environment where
this pre-written material can happen and
also great improvised moments can happen
uh this is a bag that just goes over the
dress
they're nice in a time when the pandemic
has just been so hard for so many people
we had this opportunity to release this
movie that could make millions of people
laugh and feel connected to each other
i love that everyone got to watch it at
the same time it really felt like this
kind of global event
in a way that we hadn't really seen all
year it's a testament to how
sasha works and how aaron and jason and
the entire team works on this film
because through all of this
process writers are working up until the
very last minute
they're tweaking lines aaron is working
on the music
jason is trying to figure out how to
position the cameras
to make the changes as sasha's maybe
going to have a different entrance
we were really working 22 to 23 hour
days
and it's a testament to how sasha works
that we just can't settle for good
enough i mean it was a
massive effort by every single person